[Musique]
julie julie surtout quand on forme un
cycle comme un oiseau sifflé il faut
serrer les lèvres pour siffler il peut
pas là tu as raison mais pourtant écoute
écoute écoute
oui si d'ici là tout comme châteauroux
est-ce que ça que chaque loup est ce que
ça te le raccourci pour le parce que sa
tâche est où sept châteaux lui contester
mais c'est lui qui m'a chambre et qui
sifflote le petit oiseau au comme il est
dur gazon les enfants du coup j'ai pas
vu petit oiseau non c'est pourtant moi
je l'entend chanter ah mais c'est julie
qui l'a dans sa main monsieur je savais
bien bonjour il et il aimerait venir
dans ce jardin
je m'entends très bien avec lui tu veux
bien nous chantait pas chansons à moi je
veux bien volontiers
vous voulez les enfants chantaient des
croix vous voulez mon idée aleri de dvd
les enfants prenaient on sait ce qu'il
écrit chaîne la grève
public
[Musique]
e
c'est un petit oiseau des îles un petit
oiseau de couleurs
si tu le vois volé dans la grand ville
suit le connaîtra pas d'un si tu veux
boire borné dans la drôme il suit le oui
tu connaîtras le bonheur
[Musique]
c'est un petit oiseau des îles qui est
entré dans mon club
il s'est posé dans ma vie tranquille et
marie je m'appelle barre il s'est posé
dans la vie tranquille mais mardi joe va
faire le bonheur
depuis ce jour là je vis un peu comme au
paradis
et si tu veux boire l'amour rien on chez
moi partout
[Musique]
c'est un petit oiseau des îles qui
mangent au creux de ma main
c'est un tout petit oiseau fragile qui
chante serait de chez le matin c'est
tintin
toi au fragile qui chantent sous la
douche le matin
[Musique]
m
depuis ce jour là je dis un peu comme au
paradis
et si tu veux voir l'amour
d'ailleurs chez moi
[Musique]
non
c'est un petit oiseau des îles un petit
oiseau de couleurs
si tu le vois aller dans la grandville
suis levé tu connaîtras le valin situe
le boy-band à la grandville cieux qui
connaîtra le bonheur
elle
si tu le bois khaled al agouri cieux et
et connaîtra de bonheur si tu doivent
aller dans le mobile suit le et tu
connaîtras le badin
[Musique]